- I remember watching Magic School Bus
in school. Do you remember?
Is it medically accurate?
We're about to find out, be-woo!
- What are you doing?
- Our class is broadcasting
two hours of live television
today, and I said I'd have a show
for them to do, and I don't, yet.
(coughing)
- That's how I feel making
every YouTube video.
And cover your mouth when
you're coughing, buddy.
- It's my opinion as your
mother and as a doctor,
that you have a fever,
which means you are sick,
which means you are going back to bed.
- How did she know he has a fever?
She did not measure his temperature.
She did not feel his forehead.
- Yes, Dr. Tennelli,
thank you for calling.
- What is this stegosaurus
that is on top of her shoulder?
- Is Ralphie staying home from
school today, Ms. Frizzle?
- I can't overstate
the importance of this,
do not send your kids to
school if they are sick.
Then it prevents the other
kids from getting sick, too.
- How can anything that smells
like grape shoe polish
help my body get well?
- Spoiler alert, it doesn't.
Cough syrup doesn't really
help you get better.
And in fact, when we
look at the research at
over-the-counter cough syrups,
they don't work that well.
Just use some magical honey,
as long as you're over the age of one.
Why am I saying it to you as if you're one
and you understand what I'm saying?
(beeping)
- [Dr. Tennelli] And don't forget
to shake well before using.
- Like this?
- (laughs) Even your jokes are sick.
- Wow.
Wow. Standup comedy?
- [Dr. Tennelli] I've gotta
go see another patient,
but grandpa's downstairs
if you need anything.
- Okay, Mama Bear, you're a doctor.
You know that if you're
kissing your son who is sick,
you're potentially getting yourself sick,
thereby getting your patient sick.
Don't do that.
- Good afternoon, I'm Ralphie,
and this is the Frizzle News Network.
- I need to know what
this brontosaurus is.
(screaming)
(upbeat music)
(suspenseful music)
- [Dorothy Ann] The FNN News Team
is nearing the disaster area.
- Okay, so they're in
the oral pharynx here.
They're by the uvula,
that little punching bag
that hangs from the back of your throat.
It looks like they're going
low to check out the tonsils,
the pharynx, maybe even the
larynx if they go low enough.
- Oh, get a shot of those
vocal chords, class!
- [Tim] Look how red and
swollen his throat is.
- Most kids when they have a sore throat,
it's not their vocal chords
that are the problem.
It's usually higher up.
Tonsils, which is why
you hear tonsillitis,
or pharyngitis, which is just
your typical sore throat.
But that is higher than the
larynx, so I don't know why
they ventured all the
way down to the larynx.
- It's not as easy for us or germs
to get inside the body as you might think.
- Yeah, skin pretty much covers it.
- Yo, what is this pterodactyl
that's just in every scene?
- I've got it!
- The nose!
(suspenseful music)
- Look at this!
Is it just me or does
this say, this way in?
- How are you gonna get into the mouth
through a scab on your thigh?
That is one journey the Magic School Bus
probably won't make.
- We're all gonna die!
(digital beeping)
- It's a shortcut, get it? Shortcut?
- [All] Carlos!
- I love puns. Carlos, not a good pun.
- Wow!
- Dude, what is this triceratops
doing? Someone tell me.
- For every trip, there's a roadmap.
- [Girl] That's Ralphie's bloodstream.
- Good bloodstream.
♪ We'll take the
trans-Ralphie highway system ♪
And here we go, wa-hoo!
- What doesn't make sense to me is,
let's say they take the venous
system back up to his throat.
The venous system doesn't
empty at his throat,
it empties into the heart.
In order to get to the
throat, they need to take
the venous system back to
the heart, from the heart,
back up to the throat, and
then from the capillaries,
kind of enter the throat?
Diffusion?
(TV static)
- And it doesn't even hurt!
- This kid's not panicking?
There's a velociraptor
sitting next to him.
(adventurous music)
They ventured into a capillary.
Those are red blood cells floating around.
(children yelling)
Platelets, white blood cells
floating in there as well.
- [Ralphie] That stuff is clear.
- [Ms. Frizzle] That's right, Ralphie.
The liquid part part
of the blood is clear.
- It's actually not clear,
it's yellow. It's plasma.
We talked about this. If you haven't,
video linked down below.
- Are they what make blood-
- What is this ankylosaurus doing
watching television and filming?
- They're called red blood cells,
and the white ones are white blood cells.
- [Ralphie] But what are
those jaggedy things?
- Platelets. - [Ms. Frizzle]
Those are platelets.
- [Dorothy Ann] They help the
body heal scrapes and cuts.
- That's true, blood has
the four components there,
platelets, white blood cells,
red blood cells, and plasma.
Plasma makes up 55% of your blood,
and it's yellow, so your
blood's really yellow.
- Bacteria are germs.
Once inside our bodies,
they can make us sick.
Ralphie has a bacterial infection!
- What a great diagnosis,
and that's absolutely true,
bacterial infections do make us sick.
They can give us sore throats,
that's why you hear the term strep throat.
Sore throats, the majority of time,
aren't caused by bacterial
infections, are caused
by viruses, therefore,
not requiring antibiotics.
Such an important point.
- Look, here comes a white blood cell.
It's throwing stuff at the bacteria.
- Basically what happens is the bacteria
gets labeled as foreign.
It starts getting attacked and eaten alive
by the macrophages.
The neutrophils start
multiplying in number.
And doing an inflammatory cascade,
you actually call on
more white blood cells
to come on and beat up on this bacteria.
But then remember, when you're
having this inflammatory
cascade, it's also causing
damage to the surrounding tissue.
The way I like to explain this
is imagine a war just went on
on some really beautiful grass,
and even though the good guys won,
and they're all safe and sound,
the grass got pretty torn
up. That's your throat.
That's what needs time to
heal. That's why it hurts.
- No wonder I'm sick.
- There's a spinosaurus
hiding underneath his blanket.
- I'm going to try and
get an exclusive interview
with these two bacteria.
- If you ever run into a
bacteria, do not interview it.
They will infect you.
Infect you.
I just saw an iguanodon pop up.
(cheerful music)
The plesiosaur just
turned on the television!
- [Ralphie] Is that the
medicine mom gave me earlier?
- [Ms. Frizzle] It sure is.
- Okay, take back what
I said, it looks like
the mom slash doctor
gave him an antibiotic.
How did she know it was bacterial?
I don't know because she
didn't do a strep test.
She didn't do a throat culture.
I feel like this is encouraging
the overuse of antibiotics,
but maybe I'm taking it too seriously
because it's a cartoon.
- Does it mean what I think it means?
Oh no, Ralphie's antibodies
have marked the bus as bacteria.
- The macrophage is about
to eat the magic school bus.
Why isn't the apatosaurus
waking Ralphie up
so he can save them?
- Ralphie's white blood cells
will have to catch us first.
(engine revving)
(adventurous music)
- It's a good thing bacteria
don't have hovercraft engines
or turbines on the back of them
to escape white blood cells.
(alarm ringing)
I've never seen a pteranodon
use an alarm clock before.
This is certainly a first.
(sneaky music)
(gong resonating)
This brachiosaurus is
really getting witty.
- We left Ralphie's throat
and are now heading up his
nasal pharyngeal passages.
- Prediction time.
They're gonna get clumped
in a piece of mucus
and they're gonna get sneezed
right out. Final answer.
- We're up Ralphie's nose?
- [All] Ew!
- They're like, throat, cool, nose, ew!
What's the difference?
(sneezing)
Why is the mosasaurus sneezing?
Can you get inter-species
infectivity like this?
- I get it!
I've gotta sneeze them out,
but I don't feel like sneezing.
(sneezing)
- This diplodocus is one smart dino.
- [Doctor] Sorry, Liz,
but I can't hear a thing.
- Do dilophosauruses even have lungs?
- Getting all your shots is
another way to keep healthy.
Shots help your body be prepared
for some of the really tough germs.
- A vaccine is like a wanted poster
where you essentially tell
all your cells to be ready
for this foreign invader
in case it does come along.
- [Girl] Hey, does Ms.
Frizzle ever get sick?
- No way!
She takes good care of herself,
gets all of her shots, and she's magic.
- I don't think that's an
accurate representation to kids.
It's okay to get sick.
You will get better. The
body needs challenges.
Without challenges, that's how
autoimmune problems happen.
Medical shows are fun, but
medical games are even more fun.
Check out this video of me
playing Surgeon Simulator.
I make a really good surgeon.
Not accurate, but very fun to watch.
Click here, check it out. As
always, stay happy and healthy.
(whispering) Click it.
Operation.
(upbeat music)